real key of the perfect camera it's the
steel page from GoPros playbook let's
shoot a little short scene I'm gonna go
from sab to set up the same camera in
the same configuration with no downtime
here we go back in 2009 I moved out to
Los Angeles with Sam and we go to film
sets a mood laugh at their tech because
his old clunky heavy inefficient it
needed a whole team of people just to do
a simple shot cuz we were a bunch of
computer nerds and we had applied a
computer nerd Street to our camera
technology with these sleek little
digital things that could do things that
the big boys didn't think we could do
but you know what I've been resting on
my laurels the past couple years the
cinema world well they caught up to us
they got real nerdy also we lost our
edge now they're doing things that we
can't do with little tattoos that we
don't have it's time to fix that I'm
going to reapply minor distri I'm going
to reimburse from the womb of camera
tech I'm going to build the perfect
camera now there's so many options here
I'm like I'm all jazzed up about trying
to figure out how I'm gonna make this
work vnh has agreed to work with us on
making this perfect camera build they
want to see what it looks like they want
to see what does a perfect camera me now
we've heard them a couple years here
they're gonna be hooking us up the
various pieces of gear that we need
here's the problem I don't know where to
start
I'm gonna gather up all the guys we're
gonna sit down we're gonna figure out
just what do you need in a camera
package all these little details that
you never think about what makes a
perfect camera 13 plus stops of dynamic
range so that rules out a lot of cameras
right there
fine okay if the perfect camera allows
me to make mistakes a good Wireless
follows right control it with the
internal lens motors the technology
exists let's use it
I think PL lenses are a byproduct of
dinosaur cameras no rolling shorter
built-in ND filters to shoot raw I want
to make as many mistakes on set as
possible it needs to be smart across
Reds are 3d black magic rods also smart
high bitrate and these two have a
monitor
right yes right good look at a camera
Bluetooth audio for monitoring
yeah wireless video village less than 10
pounds less than 20 no cuz Kimball's
can't hold 20 pounds sounds into camera
wirelessly so I want the carrier to be
able to instantly pop up on things pop
into another thing something that can be
put down easily and you've also set on
good thermal management low light
waveforms audio levels 12 rolling the
next thing to do is to talk about what
tools can actually achieve this and can
we actually build this Berga camera the
real key is the perfect camera is steel
page from GoPros playbook GoPro
basically just makes a small cube of the
camera and you can put that cube into
any rig you need do you want it on your
forehead do you want it on a tripod do
you want it in a gimbal do you want it
on a drone that falls out of the sky all
of these solutions and more can be yours
when you use the GoPro system and I was
inspired by that to get this shoulder
not here this is called a dovetail mount
it's like a wedge and you slide a plate
on top of it charm is called a bridge
plate a piece of metal that's kind of
cut like this some screws in the top
slides on more than half the price of
the shoulder aid for a stupid little
plate hood companies had all the
features you'd want in a camera you
never have to buy another camera big
camera man and the idea is that at the
bridge plate on top of that I have an
adapter for the quick-release plate that
goes on our tripod fluid ed putting just
porting the camera on this it's going to
cost me eight hundred and fifty dollars
I got all this different gear and I'm
gonna try it all and then once I figure
out exactly what we need I'll hold on to
that and we'll be all set and we never
had a baseplate for it now I do
ooh here it is
ideally we just have the camera built
permanently and we don't have to
continue building it all the time
assign handles will be attached to
another quick release plate getting that
if you guys want there's a link in the
description below to all the gear we use
to go check it out
our old brain with the new Gemini
sensitive they used to be on the helium
which was aka the Gemini is 5 K and you
might be like what that's a downgrade
psych it's a lateral move it has much
better low-light sensitivity and dynamic
range oh that's nice they changed the
fright they changed the plate
there we go cut dual is o on this that
means it can shoot natively at 800 ISO
and 3200 ISO noiseless the a7 is using a
post noise reduction on the footage
whereas this is just tuned I just love I
love the craftsmanship at red but I also
like how when they replace the sensor
they go around on the outside of the
camera too and they put Gemini 5k there
and 5k 5k it's 35 there just watch out
that haven't haven't screwed those on
yet but what's fun about these red
cameras is the former kind of a
relationship with them it's it's the
same camera but now it's just a little
different right and each time we've each
each red we've had we've upgraded
[Music]
I'm sure on your screen you can see that
this is brighter than that right this is
32 for me
what are you 6400 like that and and and
and we're getting a really clean image
here looks really good
do not I get you 240 frames per second
and like regular light problem trying to
control the focus on your camera with a
hand on the lens not only destabilizes
your camera very often you don't have an
extra hand to put on the lens if you're
shooting on a gimbal no good you want to
have both hands to stabilize the camera
solution Wireless focus pulling not
using your phone not using Wi-Fi but
using good old-fashioned radio control
no I don't regret making fun of those
antennas this unit let's be full focus
without having to touch the camera or
the lemon I don't need a rail I don't
need a motor
I don't need a whole bunch of cables
literally just camera body the lens and
this little thing that goes around the
side of the camera body as it goes part
of the camera to begin with I needed a
way to control the camera so in the past
and be our touchscreen and if I took a
touchscreen off replaced with a small HD
monitor which was wonderful
I then use the side-handle controller
which has a little d-pad and enter
button and it was actually pretty great
because a touchscreen is cool but you
really don't finger smudges all of your
screen at the end of the day is it
working that's just using the the servo
motors in the lens loop no cables no
race no motors we're waiting years to
like this problem if you're operating
camera and your friend is blowing focus
well now you don't want them just
breathing in your ear looking at the
monitor like the hot Carmichael 713
right now at the camera
you ought them off on their own with
their own monitor it needs to be
Wireless you give them the wireless
focus give them wireless video this is
the small HD bolt 500 this is the Rx and
this is the TX that since our
transmitter and receiver this is a
wireless monitor system lets you mount a
monitor to your camera and it transmits
wirelessly to a second monitor Thank You
small HD
problem if I want to listen to my camera
audio that look like Carmichael does
right now with cables all over the place
solution I just got a cheap little
Bluetooth adapter that I filmed the
camera and now
I can hear what I'm hearing with these
headphones it's great
Bluetooth oh boy why isn't that being
built into cameras now my other friend
who's getting audio can also be wearing
Bluetooth headphones and he can hear
exactly what his kidding problem you
used to have to use XLR cables to run
audio to camera solution we're using the
Sennheiser g4 system wirelessly sending
an audio from our boom to our camera or
records into the camera you need really
good lenses you do need really good
lenses we use the Sigma lenses the Sigma
Art Series lenses they're like Canon L
Series lenses but even better that's
right
Canon L Series lenses are nice Sigma Art
Series lenses are nicer GoPro basically
just makes a small cube of the camera
you can put that cube into any rig you
need and I built this system
[Music]
I've made the perfect camera this is the
core of the camera right it's not really
organ ama quit so ever but I can go into
handheld mode right here
now I'm handheld the the best handheld
rig I've ever made immediately boom we
are alive and we are in the shoulder
monitor notice I'm going from rig to rig
without changing a single thing on the
camera get my slide and shots there it
is wow I'm on as a tripod adding a third
leg kept her from falling over right
gimble's gimble's are the future they
make things super stable so I found this
gimbal this is the leanest helix notice
way it's designed they've made it really
compact where all your three axes are
built in here right in the center so you
can take it you can set it down
alright so now you've seen me take this
camera and move it from rig to rig to
rig to rig let me take the battery off
outside of that I don't have to change a
single thing on the camera here pop it
into here the gimbal itself powers
camera which saves me weight or just
awesome there it is
I got a gimbal it works great I know I
hear what you're saying but Nico if you
change lenses you got every balance
you're right I only have to rebalance
Poor's and backwards because I kept the
lens in line with the roll axis a lot of
to do is super on heavy or too back
heavy slide it forwards and backwards
and that's it
so many being able to wirelessly pull
focus somebody being able to wirelessly
monitor somebody somebody being able to
wirelessly pump audio into it well
somebody can wirelessly hear the audio
is just it's exactly what you need on a
gimbal and I don't have to worry about
suddenly having a strip my camera part
or having a B camera or a C camera on
any of these other rigs I'll have to do
at the end of the day I'll go back to
another rig pop this off camera eh
that's helped make this all possible if
you guys want to see any of these pieces
I'm using want to buy any of them for
yourselves check out the link in the
description below
it goes to site B th built us a web page
for this set up let's shoot a little
short scene I'm gonna go for set to set
up the same camera in the same
configuration with no downtime here we
go
[Music]
hand it over
not a million years million and one we
got from B&H this isn't it cool you want
to check up the rest of the pieces of
our perfect camera rate you can click
the link in the description below
because we also got that stuff from B&H
battery in here so should be okay signal
I'm a perfect camera all right here's
the shot I thought I could fluke my way
out of this one not today we need to be
pulling a iris rec yeah so yeah exactly
so let's get that set and we'll do a
shot need some marks Nikko you remember
our third story about this from the
revenant yep yep you're really high
expectations and three two one action
are you gonna help him show his skills
for smoothest no I'm gonna help him show
that his Gimbels the smooth him great
right you guys don't even want to know
what's in this case you guys don't even
want to know I'm willing to risk it all
to show this to the world the video dude
Sam Sam's Sam's ultimate price Sam pays
the ultimate price to prove how smooth
Niko's Gamble really is there really is
amazing that really is crazy speedin
cut shoulder hey here's the moment of
truth just nature gimbal shot how
quickly they move to our next rig and be
all set up
okay and last but not least I'll deal
with cable management all the time you
realized he had another older small HD
monitor the 502 and I can just leave
that on the shoulder mount permanently
so I can look at it the whole time I'm
filming and I can leave the other
monitor on the top and Nick and still
get this Wireless quick yeah like I'm
ready before the crew is you hurry up
boy we got filmin to do you know stop
rendering if you need like that like a
backpack that I consider that would be
perfect changed give me the case no I
said give me the case you can't get more
serious fine okay this case looks nice
from the outside huh but it's what's on
the inside that matters
yeah and personal action hand over the
case bubsy no my cold dead body won't
give you another chance hand over yeah
okay I need a camera cart yeah when you
just bring all the way that's true I do
unplug the smarter pop this off
pop it in I'm going to pull focus let's
stop but I'm also I'm gonna pull focus
for this one so Nick go ahead take a
coffee break this is the other briefcase
back to Clinton kind of difference would
be nervous and calm the perfect camera
lets me concentrate on what really
matters
keeping Clinton stammering goofing off
too much Hey the crew and the cast is
good I need this kind of a camera rig
saw in action you set it down you open
it up wow wow wow wow wow wow sounds
great yeah we go there we go good job
guys I feel great
honestly the rigs worked awesome the
gimbal worked great popping the camera
from handheld the shoulder mount to
slider was all awesome a shoulder mount
was super convenient honestly doing
dialogue slider looked really nice being
able to not worry about focus and just
letting Nick handle that was super cool
yeah I'm really honestly super happy if
any of you guys out there are budding
filmmakers or seasoned filmmakers
honestly it doesn't really matter what
range you're at if you'd like to check
out our kit head on over to the link in
the description below
benh has made a webpage just for us show
us all the things here so you can get
yourself
the monitors we're using the sound
system we're using the assistant camera
interfaces the gimbal anything you want
to look at it's all there and it's great
I'm really really happy with this this
is going to make it so it can make
really cool stuff on corridor without
huge budgets without huge crews and
honestly I feel like I'm back on the
front of that technological line finally
applying technology to let me do what
they do have a expensive film sets
without the budget without the crew and
that's that's good here's to a couple
more years
awesome corridor videos before I need to
make the perfect camera version - you
never told anyone to subscribe hey
subscribe to